things may be slowly returning to normal
in Wuhan but elsewhere in the world
countries are closing their borders to
stop the spread of kovat 19 that's
leaving many families divided Russia has
banned all foreigners without a
permanent residence permit from entering
leaving dozens of people trapped inside
airports DW caught up with one couple
who were separated returning from their
honeymoon couch oh this isn't on shed
Abena after returning from his honeymoon
he became separated from his wife and
stuck in the transit zone of Moscow's
Vnukovo Airport along with around 20
other people he's in almost constant
contact with his wife to let her know
how he's doing
Antonis stuck because he's Ukrainians
and a new government ordered to stop the
spread of the coronavirus bans
foreigners from entering the Russian
Federation dude we have to live here
sleep here eat here and passengers from
arriving and departing flights often
come through so the government order is
supposed to prevent infection it's not
very infective becoming separated from
her husband at the airport is not how
Anton's wife Jeanne and Shippuden I
thought their honeymoon would end she's
Russian so she was able to enter the
country the couple got married at this
Moscow registry office just a few weeks
ago newlyweds we only managed to be
together as a family for 12 days now
it's not clear how long we'll be apart
until now I didn't think that we would
get caught up in this confusing inhumane
bureaucratic machine Anton is not the
only one stuck in a Moscow terminal
hundreds of Central Asian migrants have
also been camping out at fluke 'va
Airport many of them are from Uzbekistan
which has closed its borders due to the
corona virus
they hope to get a rare flight home but
you've genious nightmare suddenly came
to an end unexpectedly the government
changed course
and amended the rules now foreigners can
enter Russia if they have Russian family
members and have the documents to prove
it like all the problems of the world
including the coronavirus and all of the
economic crises have suddenly taken a
backseat because now the most important
person in my life is with me and we can
take on the world together Anton and
Eugenia were lucky but at Moscow's
airports many others are still stuck in
limbo